if brett akamoto tweets out a match-up
any date
take it to the grave because that he
works for espn which
the ufc works for it used to be ariel
right and ariel had a fallen out with
ufc and dana white now
it's brett akamoto is their cash cow
media guy so brett is if if it comes
from brett you can take it's happening
brett tweeted out
that
sugar shawn o'malley is fighting peter
yon i don't understand that i don't
either i because soon as i went why
would they do that sugar okay i want
sugar to now i know they were talking
[ __ ] to each other
that's fine but i want sugar to kind of
be
like i want him to be fabulous and
fantastic and keep winning and keep
developing and then and then in two
years
in three years
you're talking like somebody who cares
about sugar show
well you're talking like you have
actually no no no hold on i'm actually
talking like somebody who actually cares
about the usc too because he's a big
star so you create like i hate this
you know maybe i hate this right not and
it's not because can chicashon beat
peter yan 100 100 not a bad bet 100
my issue is is and i tell us that every
young when five second food truck
whatever they ask for advice i say dude
it is a marathon not a sprint right the
media the ufc the fan base is gonna push
you for these huge tough fights right if
you're not getting paid to fight those
huge tough fights if you don't have the
experience under your belt you are
cutting your career in half and for what
from the pressure from fans and now you
see the comments on what why would they
do this what well hold on
because there's uh
hundreds of thousands of people going oh
sure sean's never fought anybody you
need to fight somebody so that narrative
he tries to ignore it right and put
sugar's on social he's on [ __ ] twitch
eventually he's like they're right
i need to prove myself no you don't
you're making more money than god
outside the octagon you got [ __ ]
rainbow hair but you let this get to you
and your coaches go you know what let's
shut them up okay cool
if you remember
your manager should be saying the same
[ __ ] i'm saying it is a marathon not a
sprint right let's go through b let's go
through his path he's fighting peter
young in september
all right october
here's such a [ __ ] so b let's go through
it let's go through it
you're
you're
you know what let's put in your sugar
sean o'malley
and um uh just a reporter going through
it
so let's say best case scenario hey chin
bring up the rankings for me would you
rather bring up the rankings for me
where sugar shawn's at because by the
way you can replace sugar shawn within
my brian ortega too i would have brought
him up way slower personally
don't get me started on take it i mean
do not miss a great look ask header
gracie what happened when i when they
announced one of his fights i called him
and begged him not to think they did
didn't recommend the same same different
conversation so i'm a reporter you're
you're sugar shawn o'malley you just
knocked out peter young right you're
just not pr the number one guy in the
world and you're right number 13 right
yeah
we tried giving you the number nine guy
pedro munoz who was a ideal stylistic
matchup for you in the top ten sure you
beat peter young hold on you beat peter
yan right mm-hmm
what's after that
well uh
which remains a giant named alger man
sterling or because al jermaine and tj
dillashaw have to fight or tj dillashaw
now are those guys good at wrestling
i'm just no i'm asking you right are
they good i i
no i'm just asking you dude are they
would you say they're fairly good at
wrestling
only if you think
only if you consider like [ __ ] a
whirlwind a whirlwind banshee like right
so hey b let me ask you this
would you consider algerian sterling
have good wrestling
just a little bit just a little bit yeah
he has good wrestling yeah peter young
out wrestled al germain
yeah multiple times tripped him a lot
with those [ __ ] trips now this last one
he lost and aldrin got his back and you
know he proves how good alterman is
correct so i'll join his pretty good
wrestling tj is pretty good at wrestling
pretty good sugar shawn
phenomenal stand up very hard to train
for
good jujitsu
after you beat peter yan it does not we
can't protect you anymore i want to see
we this is our last time we can protect
protecting you meaning
you're going to be fighting monsters
pedro munoz is not an easy test peter
young not an easy [ __ ] test but
stylistically we can see how you have
advantages in those fights outside those
two in this current
situation we're living in in the top ten
do you know what i'm doing a lot of
upside do you know what i weigh about
how long have you been fighting you know
what i would rather see him fight
corey
100 that's what i wanted for that's what
but peter young the former world
champion it's just a
an assassin a murderer
like high level like striking like just
i don't know man and i'm not saying i'm
not saying sugar can't beat anybody on
the planet it's just that like you said
to your point i want to see this guy be
shine and be a huge for how long for how
long i would don't ask me i'm the wrong
guy to ask for 10 years probably yeah
it'd be a great career yeah i'm keeping
him i'm keeping him
i'm keeping you on the fast track you
know you got the fast pass
ufc land this is the fastpass in ufc
land and you're going through the park
quicker you'll be exhausted though no my
my issue is that i think sugar shawn has
all the talent in the world but like
with everything in fighting it takes
time to develop that's why boxers they
bring you up slowly you get developed
slowly you you fill those holes in your
game you throw you throw them to some
[ __ ] high-level wrestler
it's like i don't feel like seeing sure
and just so you guys know
sugar shawn
nate diaz hamzat
izzy
jon jones the big names volkanovsky the
big games you know who decides who
fights each other right
no dana white
[Music]
my